[MUSIC PLAYING]
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Hi, I'm Kelsey
Hightower, a staff developer
advocate for Google
Cloud Platform.
MATT HOOKER: And
hi, I'm Matt Hooker,
an engineer at HashiCorp,
working on Packer.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: All right.
This is the third video
in a series covering open
source tools from HashiCorp
and how we can use them
with Google Cloud Platform.
In the last video,
you learned how
developers can create repeatable
development environments
with Vagrant.
In this video, Matt and I
are going to cover Packer.
Matt, can give us an
overview of Packer?
MATT HOOKER: Yeah.
Thanks, Kelsey.
I'd be happy to.
Packer may at first seem a
lot like Vagrant in the sense
that it can be used
to define the software
and configuration for a VM.
But unlike Vagrant, the
artifact it produces
is a machine image, as
opposed to a running VM.
The machine image can be used
to create VM's preconfigured
exactly how you want them all
through a simple Packer config
file.
This is where it gets cool.
With a single configuration
and common specification,
Packer can produce
almost any machine image
like Google Compute Engine,
other cloud providers,
and even Docker images.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
Packer is pretty dope.
I've used it in quite
a few of my projects,
and know a few
people using Packer.
In fact, I'm the original author
of the GCE builder for Packer,
going back many years now.
MATT HOOKER: Nice,
I didn't know that.
OK.
Then you might have some
kind of demo or something
you could show us.
Right?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
That's why we're here.
Continuing the story
from last time,
we're going to create a GCE
image based on a similar config
you saw in the Vagrant video.
You'll recall from
that video that Vagrant
was to be used by developers,
but the main goal of creating
their application and sharing
across a Vagrant VM on Google.
Now we're going to start
sliding the perspective
from our developer view
over to our operations
view where you want to
deploy these images on GCE
for the running the
app for our users.
So the image we're
going to create
will have our '80s
style arcade game,
and its dependencies
installed and configured
to start at boot time.
Matt, how do we get started?
MATT HOOKER: Let's do it.
You want to start by
going to Packer.io
and downloading the version
appropriate for your platform.
In the last video, you saw how
to set up your GCP project,
so we'll skip that
part this time,
but I think this time we're
going to use a GC instance.
Right, Kelsey?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Right.
I have a machine called DEV
that we're going to use.
We're going to be using Packer
to create a new GCE operating
system image.
I'll first show you what
we currently only have,
the standard GCE
images available to us.
MATT HOOKER: Great.
Now let's flip over to our
terminal on the DEV instance
where I already have
Packer installed,
and my Packer config
file ready to go.
Let's kick off the
image field process
now with the Packard
build command.
OK.
Now that we've got
that going, let's
take a look at the hyperspace
JSON config file we're using.
Packer config files
have two primary parts.
A section that
specifies builders
and another for provisioners.
In our builder section, you
can see that I'm not only
defining the variables needed
to produce the Google Compute
Engine image, I'm
specifying attributes
such as the base
operating system
and the name of the new image.
Let's take a quick look at
the provisioner section.
Packer allows you to
customize the image
with any number of
provisioner types,
like basic shell scripts,
which is what you see here,
or even using other
configuration management
tools such as Chef,
Puppet, Ansible, et cetera.
But back to the
topic of builders.
Kelsey, do you want
to describe how Packer
builds an image for a GCP?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: You bet.
First, Packer spins
up a new instance
with the base image
that was described.
Then, Packer will
SSH into the new VM,
and apply any
configuration defined
in the provisionary section
of the Packer config.
Here, we're basically
reusing the shell script
you saw on the Vagrant
video, but split it out
into its own file.
Let's see how the
build process is doing.
OK.
Looks like it's running through
those provisionary steps
and our shell scripts.
We'll skip ahead
here a little bit,
even though I know
we all love watching
deadman packages install.
Once the provision and
customizations have finished,
Packer will terminate
the running GCE instance,
but will leave behind
the Persistent Disk,
or PD as we like to call it.
The PD contains the
base operating system,
and our customizations,
and is used in a template
to create the new GCE image.
Once the image is created,
Packer deletes the PD,
so there aren't any leftover
resources in your GCP project.
MATT HOOKER: It's finished.
Let's take a look at
the list of images now.
And sure enough, there's
our new hyperspace image.
We can even quickly spin
up a new GC instance
with our brand new image.
I'll click the checkbox
next to the image,
and click the Create
Instance button.
I'll keep all the defaults, but
since hyperspace is a web app,
I'll enable the HTTP firewall
rule for the instance,
and then click Create.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Hey, Matt.
While we're waiting for this
new instance to come up,
let's take a look at the
console output as it's booting.
You can hit Refresh and see
the new console output show up.
OK.
The instance is up.
Let's click on the IP
address to see what happens.
Bam!
Now, that's dope.
MATT HOOKER: Great demo, Kelsey.
Obviously one of the
biggest strengths of Packer
is the ability to
produce equivalent images
across multiple cloud providers.
We definitely hear of customers
that want multi-cloud support.
So it's been great to see Google
contributing to the project.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: All right.
Thanks, Matt, for
joining us today.
MATT HOOKER: My pleasure.
It's been a lot of fun.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: All right.
Thanks everyone for watching.
Don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
to keep up with more of
the videos in the series.
We've got more coming for how
you can use other HashiCorp
tools with GCP.
Also take a look
at the description
to see some of the work our
colleague has done on creating
an automated image builder
using Jenkins, Packer,
and Kubernetes.
All
Right.
Thanks for watching.
Make sure to check out our last
video in the series as well
as the playlist, and
don't forget to subscribe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]